the withdrawal from the baltimore may be
a huge setback for ukraine
but these soldiers are relieved to be
out
the other side had good heavy weapons we
prayed the entire time
and said goodbye to our lives hundreds
of times
president petra poroshenko is traveling
to the region to meet his troops
it's meant as a show of strength despite
the pullback
but his own political survival is also
at stake
poroshenko said the russian-backed
separatist had shown the world
their true face into baltimore and the
army
is trying to limit the damage it said
the pull out was an orderly withdrawal
not a retreat
80 of all ukrainian units have now left
de balsava
soon they will all be withdrawn
in the west the condemnation was
unanimous
germany said the separatists had
seriously strained the minsk ceasefire
agreement
and jeopardized hopes for peace but
moscow took a different view
foreign minister sergey lavrov called
debaltseva the exception to the rule
he said the ceasefire had otherwise held
along the entire front
and the separatists had begun to
withdraw their heavy weapons
with fighting into baltimore now over
the question
is whether the cease-fire will start to
take hold there as well